[Musique]
nicolas dupont aignan vous savez qu aura
tous les candidats ce soir et je
voudrais qu'une phase une petit
solitaire du offert à tous les candidats
voilà c'est un candidat j'aurai qu'on
fasse une petite interview race raoult
dark age ou montre des candidats vont me
dit c'est pour vous il saura sera on
dark a dans la vie regardez attention
jean luc mélenchon ra sera ou il est
d'arca il est là il est courageux plus
tôt darren clarke plus tourner d'arcade
accord très bien attention d'arcane moi
je pense qu'il est dark ale on l'a déjà
reçu dans cette émission françois fillon
j'aime pas moi j'ai un amour propre je
me fais pas offrir mais costard d'accord
asra il coûte ratera donc donc il ratera
un virage sera oui parce que je vais
vous dire au delà du canton est un peu
d'amour propre comporte pas des vestes
aux fins de palaiseau combien votre
votre costume au jour là oui moi j'ai
pas majeur ils sont euros 4 euros rien
vérifié et ben et moi je leur en prend
tout de suite à 150 moi même grâce à
audard cap emmanuel macron rats sera
parce qu'il est très faux culs adacore
[Applaudissements]
benoît hamon finira sera ni dernier à
denis voilà exactement je veux pas me
fâcher avec tout le monde d'accord déjà
sachez qu'au journal de mon prochain
attention marine le pen race raoudha
alors là selon ce que je dis ça va être
le déchaînement il tracera d'ici jeudi
rats sera tout le monde est content pour
la pré sensé si j'ai des arts quatre ans
ni l'un ni l'autre
vous dites dylan est lourde et m'a dit
l'autre comme de marne voilà très bien
je dis pas merci il reste le dernier
regardez c'est qu'il version ans
hollande race radoja sera
merci nicolas dupont aignan